[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
Elena is in Sand Diego Elena welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi George hi John can you hear me
okay yes how can we help okay um well
thanks for having me I um I started
paying off that my husband and I we
started Dave Ramsey we're in baby step 2
about a year ago um and we're posed with
this question
um if we should sell our house to pay
off the rest of our debt or most of it
um so some history and historical
information here um my mom has a rental
property and she lives with
us her tenants are going to be leaving
in the next three to four months and she
said why don't we move to my house and
you guys can pay less you just cover the
mortgage and it's significantly less and
then you can either rent your house or
sell it um and so my husband wants to
sell the house because he's done with my
gazelle intensity and I'm wondering if
we should just rent it or if we should
just sell it and get on the other side
of the
debt lot of layers to this financial
chasu let let's break this down no it's
good it's good so there's a relational
component because that piece you just
dropped a little bomb right there of my
husband is done with my gazelle
intensity and the other piece of this is
it sounds like it's about to get real
messy moving into Mom's but we don't
actually own it we're just paying her
the mortgage amount we get to keep our
hours and now we're landlords but we
still have the debt and so this I don't
know that it's just on paper this is
looking like a rose I would walk
carefully either way but how much debt
do you guys
have so we've paid about 140 we still
have about
340 is that non-mortgage debt
that's student loans 340 in student
loans good God who's the surgeon
anesthesiologist give me good news
you're
attorney but still did you go to private
school Bry so I uh no I sat on interest
with these low
payments so they ballooned it's probably
more than you took
out oh over $100,000 more in interest is
this why your husband's done with this
Pro this program
so we're we we've gotten into this and
it's been a good year but I mean I I can
just keep going but he's like he's ready
to be done with dead what's your
household
income so our household income is about
190 200,000 is that with both of you
working that's with both of
us okay so what what do you want track
to pay off your debt by right
now I'm shooting for three years
did you have a big year just because you
had a couple of great cases or is this
is this
typical um no I sold
everything you sold your
practice I sold no so I'm in house I
don't have a practice but I sold we sold
our car and we sold a bunch of furniture
we sold just all kinds of things um and
then I do real estate on the
side okay and let's talk about the
mortgage what is your payment every
month compared to your take-home
pay um mortgage right now is about
2,800 okay and what is your take-home
pay take-home pay a month is about
11,500 okay that's net so the mortgage
is not killing you guys it's about 25%
which is great that's in our parameters
which tells me uh you've got you know
now of course you have huge payments
what are your minimum payments every
month right
now
um
so right now based on you know whatever
income driven repayment type that they
have the minimum payment for all of the
student loans is about 700 that's the
problem I would get out of this plan
unless you guys are shoveling so much on
top of it that you're actually solving
the interest problem and so I wouldn't
sell the house quite yet I don't know
that i' move in with Mom and do all
these Maneuvers in 3 years you'll be
debt free and you can make different
decisions and do it at a place of Peace
instead of fear so that would be my goal
for you yeah if you think he's
frustrated with the baby steps move in
with his mom and pay her mortgage o
they're going to set your marriage on
fire don't do that thanks for the call
Elena this is the Ramsey Show create
your free everyll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life